I'm the man you want to get married to
are you saying you will literally you
will be with that man whatever happens
the rest of your life yes for for the
vows that we're supposed to live how do
you know you can keep them I I
may think it's a choice that's the thing
like women are so willing to leave
marriages because they're not happy this
is not about happiness the most
important thing is the children and the
problem is we have a modern society
where it's me me me my feelings leave
when I feel like it instead of doing
what's best for the kids Ava I gotta say
it's a little about listening to
actually take where some of it I really
don't agree with I don't agree with the
vote stuff when I have things like that
I think there'll be a lot of people
especially older generation women
perhaps who think you know what she's
got a point